[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're ringing in the new year happy
2021.
it's we're not recording this in 2021
i'm just you know
we can still transparency we can still
celebrate it i still believe
that it's a happy 2021 yeah we're going
to make it to 20 and for you listener
you're certainly in 2021 or
later it could be it could be years
later it's like an hour people are going
to
yeah it's it's nice to know that this is
as permanent as are you saying you think
this is going to be the smithsonian
no that's a little it was not pompous of
you yeah i agree
because that what what i was saying what
does that even really mean anymore
though
to be the smithsonian and that's what
we're tackling today
new year what is that new issues to be
this cares about this institution
museum i like the smithsonian shout out
to everybody all of the mythical beasts
who work at the smithsonian
or the national archive and all that
type of stuff yeah right
um but today we got to tell you about
our expedition with our
boys yeah the campaign valley i uh
as you might have remembered uh in my
top 10
moments of the year this was one of my i
don't remember what number it was but it
was up there it was in the top ten
my favorite things that happened was our
trip that we took with the boys
me and my boys uh maybe me and my boys
locker shepherd you and your boys
what are their names lincoln and lando i
think their names are lincoln in orlando
and
uh to death valley and so we said we
would not
talk about it at all on that podcast
because
a number of stories were generated
during our short trip
that we will now share i'm so glad that
we did it you know i
i gotta say it was my idea i don't know
if that's true but i'm gonna say it
it's my idea it's like let's take the
boys on a camping trip
i i don't recall so i'll give you credit
i was i was definitely looking for
another opportunity to rent a sprinter
van
and dabble once again in that hashtag
van life
so i mean that's that's been on my mind
a lot
and you know chris and i went highlight
a 2020.
um but yeah i wanted to i wanted to give
it like a kid mode
test and i'd only use my you know
my do i call it my rig is that what you
would call my fj cruiser
uh my fj cruiser which i recently
invested you know in some work being
done
on it i got the rooftop tent that was
all for my solo trip
but the thing that i learned on my solo
trip is that
uh i needed a more efficient way to
store
things especially if i was going to take
any other beings with me
on a camping trip and i don't know if
you noticed how proud i was of my drawer
i did notice how proud you were
of your drawer yeah i got a drawer and
you might think what do you mean you got
a drawer
i got a drawer like a metal drawer
that you know if you if you're in if you
look at an suv the back of an suv you've
got the part behind the back
seats what would you call that the the
boot is what
uh christy and her family call it but i
always called the boot the thing where
your boots would go like where your feet
go in the front of the car
but i think i'm wrong actually that
doesn't make any sense
they call a trunk a boot well it's not i
mean it's not a trunk
because it's just you know the back of
an suv the back end
there's a drawer that has been made
a metal drawer to fit the entire thing
the fit
and so basically it raises the level of
the floor up so you still have all that
space
but then there's like a foot deep drawer
that covers the whole thing
and uh it's not not cheap it's not cheap
are you prepared to say how much you
paid for
one drawer to go in the back of your
truck uh
no i'm not it's a very it's a very
expensive drawer
less less than one thousand dollars okay
oh okay okay so
i actually thought it was more than a
thousand dollars so
and by the way i'm um sniffing because
of uh allergy
i've waited too long to take my pill
today
it's just you know i waited too long to
take my pill today
i hate when i bring allergies to uh your
biscuits but
every once in a while i do so anyway um
if it makes your eyes water it can look
like you're getting emotional
this drawer really is with
i was excited about time with my sons
but i was most excited about the drawer
but like pulling it out
over and over again then pushing it back
in it's so smooth
but it's funny how just one drawer
properly spaced
can change everything i mean i could
have taken really
you didn't see how inefficiently i had
packed everything
on my solo trip because i didn't have to
worry about it because you got to unpack
the stuff to get to the stuff behind the
stuff and you have to repack it to move
and i mean is your drawer
like even right now at this moment still
full of stuff so i could go camping you
can
bug out you have a bug out vehicle now i
have everything
except food okay food and water
but like equipment and like uh each
story store they're permanent lights
and ways to start fire and tools and all
that stuff
all the camping stuff the cooking stuff
it's all in there see if i owned a van
you'd be ready to go i'd have one of
those too and i'd also have a shower
a toilet a sink a burner and a
bed inside of a vehicle but would you
have a drawer
but i i'd have a lot of drawers but not
no drawers no no big ass a lot of little
i don't think a lot of little drawers
can add up to one big drawer okay i
don't know how drawer math works but
no the van was incredible i will say i
was envious of the van
i rented a different van very big from a
different
uh set of people very tall like too tall
for a drive-through
yeah like you can't get drive-through
food in this could you stand up inside
of the van
do you know i really didn't invite you
in do you know the only time
i got into your van the entire time
there's one specific time do you
remember this uh
when you did number two in my van no i
did not i was not one of the people who
didn't know you could tell that i wasn't
really
chomping at the bit for you to do number
two in my van i didn't do number two in
your van
the one time i got in your van was
when it was on the way uh
to death valley when we stopped at that
gas station
in the middle of nowhere basically it's
like it's like a uh
um it's the only it's one of the only
things on 395 like you're going up
towards mammoth
and it was that gas station that had the
subway and we ended up eating at subway
and it was the first time we had eaten a
subway in a while
yeah and we're sitting there in the
parking lot eating
shout out to the mythical beast who
worked at that subway yeah and then he
came outside and got a picture with us
yeah he did um we didn't take our masks
off
no we didn't and uh that'd be a good
example
a woman came up and started asking
questions about your van
and she was like that's right mom can
you stand up in there and i was like
well let me see
oh that's the you you literally never
went in never other than that
bad that like you never went in the van
i didn't have a need to he didn't even
need to i mean
it's while it's very big in some senses
it's still it's really like well there's
the bed in the back
taking up most of the room and then
there's the bathroom
and the sink and then there's seats and
i wasn't riding in it i was driving my
own car so i didn't feel left out
and to answer your question as a six
foot seven man with shoes on
meaning a man who was six foot seven
would choose on because i'm like six six
and a half oh
i could not stand up exactly straight
in your van i had to hunch a little bit
which is not a problem for me i'm used
to it a lifetime of hunting
has made me used to it so i think it's
probably i think it's probably
six foot five six foot six clearance
this is a different van than the one i
got before but it's basically the same
model it was one year newer
it's a 2020 one or sadies yeah for real
it's like
it's fresh off the lot kind of a thing i
they may
you know the the couple gave me like a
thorough tour but i was like
i've already you know i've already done
this i've been to utah because you
rented it from
an individual yeah like a private person
private people put their vans on
there's a website called outdoorsy yeah
uh there's probably others too but
anyway
they gave me the tour and um i yeah i
got an impression that they had they
probably had rented out just a couple of
times
it was it was very new and very fresh
kind of for them
yeah it was a very nice van uh yeah very
very detailed
tour a little little a little too
detailed i mean a 45-minute tour of
event
but i i get it you've got this like
really expensive van you're letting some
stranger use it i mean you're charging
them
and they got insurance and all this
stuff that that you have to get for it
and stuff but
still it might be a little
nerve-wracking to to rent out your
your mercedes baby but anyway we went to
death valley because at that time of
year
i mean it's it's the it was
let's see it was the hottest it broke
the record for the hottest place where
not on earth uh on earth it may be the
hottest place on earth this year it was
131
or maybe 134 degrees i don't know
fahrenheit
yeah yeah thank goodness
yeah but it you know when we went um
mid 70s during the weekend before
thanksgiving yeah it was like
perfect perfect time to be there and um
let's see so what's what's the what's
the first story we drive in
and we're you know we're taking some
good photos taking some group photos i
got one photo that
of of the boys and it looks like a a
band photo
we got we've got some really really
really good photos that we that
we'll give the kiko uh for the video
version because there's like some uh
that's right there's a video version of
this yeah on youtube if you happen to be
listening
um and uh really great photos i
took some three uh 360 photos at least i
haven't seen those yet well i think i
took it
i think i took it of the first night's
campsite and i did not take any more
which you will
learn why i didn't take any of the
second and third night's camp sites
and i got some drone footage
oh snap i got some drone footage of you
driving through that canyon
through titus canyon oh is it nice i
haven't looked at it yet okay
i'm sure it's nice nice enough i mean we
get there it's like the
this time of year and especially in that
valley this
the sun sets quick it's like 4 30 and
all this the sun goes
over the the the mountain ridge
and it and it gets really dark really
quick but we had kind of beat the sunset
to get to
the first thing we wanted to see which
was um uh some sand
dunes in the middle it's just like
uh sand dunes i don't know how else to
describe it there's some re there's like
a really tall sand dune at the northern
end but we're like right in the middle
coming in through uh stovepipe wells or
yeah
and um these are the sand dunes that are
easy to get to
and it shows there was a lot of people
on these sand dunes so it's like you're
in the middle of the desert in the
in this giant valley and we're talking
sand dunes that are
150 200 feet high maybe some of the some
of the
some of the biggest ones and
there's definitely bigger in other
places you can go to rico
the eureka dunes are like 700 feet tall
is what i've heard crazy can you imagine
that because these are giant
and it really is that kind of thing that
i've only seen in movies where
you know somebody will be in the sahara
and it's just like
they're walking up the ridge of one of
those giant sand dunes like through the
desert
yeah well there's that that exists here
and like
and the boys loved it that was a really
good call to like go there first because
we were walking out on these sand dunes
and like it's
it's really exhausting walking up these
sand dunes but like everybody had a ball
and
you know you really don't know how how
how happy they're go
you know it's i feel like it was my
mission
for my for my kids to have a good
experience you know it's like
i'm building a case for van life or at
least being an outdoorsy
person and i will say that uh both of
our teenagers
expressed some teenageness
about going before the trip before the
trip they you know
thinking that i am going to the desert i
don't really understand why you want me
to do this and
it's really going to be fun but you know
what to their credit they brought
positive attitudes they had a great
attitude right and then when we got on
those dunes it's like
before we know it shepard we get to the
highest dune
that we realistically could could
could walk to and walk up which is one
of the highest ones
in in that set of dunes and before i
know it i'll look over there and
shepherd is like halfway down the dune
doing like a log roll and just like
plumes of dust
just like yeah coming up i knew this was
going to happen because i know shepard
what i didn't know was that it would
inspire lando to ultimately try the same
thing
because you know that's not really
he's not a rolled down first figure out
if it was
if it's a good idea second kind of a
person right and i guess he
he observed shepard and um
but you know it it warms your heart as a
dad seeing your kids
barrel rolling and all four of them were
doing it down this
um sandy slopes but not the dads not the
dad not the two dads
i'm thinking about my shoulders this
this
this broad-shouldered man could just
like crumple up at an instant
i just took photos and videos i was a
cinematographer i did not
i was not a roller it was a cool start
and then
you know once we were like alarmed with
how quickly it was getting really dark
we we found
the the first place that was
that felt it felt like it could be
like an almost off-road um you
you need kind of a high-clearance
vehicle to get to a place where it would
feel isolated
and we could find a campsite not
actually not a campsite but just a spot
once you get out disperse camping
disperse camera once you get out like a
mile off the main roads you're allowed
to camp anywhere
anywhere you want in designated swaths
of land and i mean
it's it's there's a beauty to the desert
that you
that you ca it's a there's a mindset to
kind of appreciating it
but as we were driving out there and i
had
the youngest boys in the van with me and
i'm just like
this is what this van was made to do
boys we're like kind of
rollicking over some rocks and like go
going through
these um these washes with like
sheer walls on either side i mean there
are some slot canyons
yeah and we were going through that and
uh
i was like this is when i think about
what i wanted this trip to be
this this is it we're like we're getting
hey we're gonna find a good spot
death valley which now me and you have
been to three times uh
death valley has it all i you know it is
a
it is an incredible well it doesn't have
trees it doesn't have
water it doesn't have shade it has
everything that you would expect in
death valley but
just so you understand if you've never
been to death valley national park
if you are just picturing a giant empty
desert well yes that is part of it
but along the sides of the desert
there are so many different
geological formations and canyons
and just really like the kids
were immediately into how cool
the geography was right yeah when you're
driving through the world
yeah i mean it definitely it feels like
something off of a
off of a movie set like you're off
you're on a farm world
and if you just have a regular old car a
sedan or whatever you can experience a
lot of this
but if you really want to get away from
the sort of touristy spots you kind of
need a vehicle that can get there now we
had been a couple of times before
and actually we chronicled at least one
of those trips with our friend nick and
the other people that he does
over landing with and off-roading with
that's when we took the
showers naked in the uh hot springs hot
springs
um yeah so yeah it's uh you know we've
done like the
the extreme technical off-roading thing
in the fj
you and i both in that so it's like with
you know with the van and the kids and
and not a lot of confidence to be able
to
fix a problem in isolated locations like
any mechanical
or technical issues like i didn't i
don't even like to think about something
going wrong
because i just want to like be in a
place where if something goes wrong i
can just say
ice it's not up to us yeah so that
you know we didn't and and the van the
van and the rental agreement would
certainly not allow us to do it and you
want to minimize
you're managing the expectations of
children and teenagers
and they don't like to just stay you
don't want to be in the car they want to
get out and do stuff
but i will say just because you don't
like to think about something going
really wrong
doesn't mean it won't because it did yes
and we will talk about that we'll get
into that in more in a second uh but
first listen we've got
the all-new good mythical mugs
fresh for season 19 of gmm
you might say oh it's the you might even
call this an old school mug like black
mug nice
nice gmn but then you're like nope nope
nope on the other side
you've got the good methagoine with
rhett and lincoln logo so you got a two
double the logos but there's more and a
retro
styling but there's more i can't
currently reach it so
you know what let me do the honors of
helping you when you fill this thing up
with hot liquids all of a sudden it
springs to life like the desert at night
you get the cockatrice
in the night sky blowing a fiery
good mythical morning with retin link
basically inspired by
um the intro the new intro
and uh yeah so the the whole thing
with with heated liquid reveals
a night sky and
a cockatrice blowing the flame and then
when it cools down it goes away
it goes away and it's black again color
changing
scene inducing heat activated mugs
we keep upping the ante that's what we
keep doing
what's next i don't know a conscious cup
there it is it sounds like uh
something's made out of like recycled
materials
no this is a cup that thinks for you
yeah that's 20 20.
i've been letting my cups think for me
for years it just hadn't amounted to
much
see where that's left me mythical.com
whoa
2021 yeah
so that first night um you know
the older boys had to camp in a tent and
then me and lando were going to sleep in
the van
and then you and shepard are going to
sleep on top of the fj in that in that
fancy rooftop and you might ask yourself
well
why'd you make the older boys sleep in a
tent well
technically the rooftop tent that i got
is a three-man tent but if you are a
um experienced camper you know that
three person means two persons yeah it
does doesn't it
a three person tent is comfortable for
two people and
when one of the persons is as big as my
person
even if the other person is as small as
shepherd's person
it's still i mean shepard and i were
basically right next to each other
could not have comfortably gotten
another being in there with us anyway
and i mean you technically could have
gotten somebody into the van but it
would have required moving a bunch of
stuff out
yeah it would be underneath the bed
in like a bunk bed situation and we also
thought this was a good opportunity
for our teenage sons to like learn how
to like set a freaking tent up and break
it down
you know what they did it they did they
were you know i
i got to give them credit man i mean
just positive attitudes
and it just if it was just me and my
kids it would have been a lot more
challenging
yeah and i have to think the same the
other way right so it was nice that they
had
had compadres you're less likely to say
and do embarrassing things
and lose your cool both ways both the
kids and the parents when you are
co-mingled
the thing that i learned the first night
it hit me like a ton of bricks and we
talked about it
is that my previous camping experience
with christy the first time we had ever
gone on a camping excursion to two of us
and of course you were alone both of
those which are different than each
other are still
starkly different than going camping
with
multiple children because well you know
the amount of time devoted to getting
everything right that includes getting
everything right for them
i mean just like we barely had time to
sit down i mean we were scrambling to
make dinner and like
you know you got me over here cooking
burgers while you're cooking mac and
cheese and
and other stuff on your setup and
cooking is a is a
a relative term yeah i kind of i kind of
got
steaks and burgers confused and i got in
my mind that like
i know that if i overcook the burgers
it it's kind of like a steak if you
overcook the steak they're going to
complain
you don't want it well done and but you
do want ground
beef yeah unless it's been pasteurized
it was kind of dark but
everyone did seem to notice that the
burgers weren't cooked off it was more
of seared tartare
oh gosh which i didn't mind i couldn't
finish it
lando was was horrified yeah
and uh so i was like okay i'm not but
you know what i'll play to my strengths
and when we were done eating
i said you know i i'll focus on doing
some dishes and cleaning up and like i'm
i'm i'm back in my in my zone
you know in the cleaning zone there was
a lot of cleaning going on while the
older boy you were cleaning too
the older boys said you know what we're
gonna
of course it's been dark for hours after
we we're done eating
and the older boys said we're gonna
we're just gonna go off and like explore
i thought that was a good idea you know
so so locke and lincoln went off they
just walked down
the way that we came and there is
nothing no one
no other civilization or no other sign
of human activity
within sight really activity of any any
any kind just maybe there are some
plants
um not many but some and uh
so so they walk off and then i'm i'm
doing the dishes
and i'm trying to remember what happened
if you told me yeah i think
i knew as soon as they left what my plan
was uh so i come out from finishing the
dishes and the younger boys are sitting
by the fire and of course they've got
screens out i'm like boys put your
screens away
and i was like i'm gonna hang out with
you guys because you said
i'm gonna go scare loch and lincoln and
uh i'm gonna carry on the mclaughlin
tradition of
you know trying to give
your fellow campers a heart attack
shepard and
uh lando's eyes got his biggest saucers
and you walked off into the darkness
and then i'm left uh maybe i'll tell my
perspective this story and then you can
tell yours
uh so i'm sitting there at the campfire
um
talking to shepherd and lando and i'm
like
i ended up talking about i don't know
how we got on it but i started talking
to them about
i think it's because you're out camping
and you're like there's a level of end
like a spirit of independence to camping
and when i started talking about
you know our friend ben and and his
you know his adventurous spirit and the
things that he would do
in the woods and out in nature and how
he fostered stuff that we've shared with
you
you know um last year on the podcast
just
i was just kind of telling them stories
of his
all the things that he would do and then
inspire us to do
out in the woods and on canoes and how
his
you know how his parents when they were
not much older than him
would take him in his canoe and drive to
lillington and just drop him off not
much older than art shepard and lando at
the time
yeah you said not much older than him
like his parents weren't that much older
than him
no no i said not much older than them
yeah
uh lando shepard so i was like can you
imagine
me and mom driving you guys with a canoe
like to the next town over and then
you're just going to canoe down the
river and then
you know half a day half the day later
we're going to pick you back up and
they're like
they're like super into it and i'm like
yeah this is what camping's all about
you got a fire
you got these kids who are just like
expanding their
their horizons and forgetting about
their screens
and then all of a sudden i just heard
this blood-curdling scream and kerfuffle
in the way distance and i'm like
shepherd that's your dad i think he
found the older boys
and then we just waited for you to come
back and hear the story of what had
happened
well i think i've talked about this
before i mean i have a thing for scaring
people it's one of my favorite things
and uh done it all my life and it's a
family tradition my dad did it to me
um and so as soon as they left and they
had their headlamps on
right and so and there's basically we're
kind of in this
wash so it's essentially sort of like a
shallow canyon
uh and there's only so many pla they can
go this way or they can go that way they
can't
there's not many places they can go and
you can see where they're at because
it's so dark
and so i could see that they were a long
distance away because i could see their
lights because it's
so so flat and um
there was a little bit of moonlight
there was enough moonlight for me to
walk out there without a light and my
eyes were kind of adjusted to the desert
so i could kind of see where i was going
without
being in too much danger so i was like
okay i'm going to walk down
towards them and then oh i could see
them
in the distance oh they've turned back
around and now they're walking back
towards the camp site but they're still
many many hundreds of yards away from
the campsite
so i'm like um all right what am i going
to do i'm going to kind of get
on the side of this path behind
this bush and wait for them to come by
and scare the crap out of them
but then i was like man this the desert
plants are so like sparse and small and
i'm like if they're shining their head
lamp and they see me behind this very
sparse like cactus bush kind of thing
the whole thing is ruined so i was like
i'm going to move further off of
the road get down on my belly behind
this little like embankment
and let them pass and then come up
behind them
because not only is that you know
they can't see me but it will scare them
so much to have something come from
behind the unknown the unknown that
they've just been in
versus the campsite oh it makes sense
that somebody that we know might be
on that side so they come they walk in
they walk they walk by me and then
didn't you hear lock say something well
here's the deal i had to stand
up and start kind of walking towards the
road and as i stood up after they passed
after they passed as i stood up and
started taking a couple of steps
they sort of heard something and then
and then like later we find out
locke was like looking did you hear
something and he was like no
and anyway and locks like so lock is
paranoid
already scared he'd been scared the
whole time he's kind of skittish in
general
yeah he's scared he's like he's like in
the dark
and so he's looking over his shoulder
not seeing anything i
i and then i gotta stop and but then i
then i get a walk out into the middle of
this basically this dirt road that
they're walking down
and then i start taking more and more
steps and then right before i really
start running where they're gonna know
i probably get you know 10 feet behind
them and i was like i'm gonna let out
the lowest
most guttural sound that i can make that
will sound as
unhuman as possible and i was just like
okay and um lock screamed
i don't think lincoln screamed i didn't
hear him scream i heard lock scream
but then when they tell the story what
do they say that they each thought
uh loc thought it might be bigfoot
which is what i which is what i was
hoping
and lincoln said that his brain was
saying
he was super scared but he was thinking
if that's not rhett i don't know what
we're gonna do
yeah yeah you know you know he he kind
of had
he was in he was he's more of a
strategic thinker than me
you know he knows how to play chess
right um
yes i was encouraged that like he didn't
he didn't lose his cool
completely but i know he was scared
because
you know when they tell the story when
they came back up
and the three of you walked back like
they just had this like sweaty
exasperated
wide-eyed like like heart rate still
pumping kind of vibe and i could tell
that lincoln was legitimately scared
along with like who would you say it's
scary i mean it's not as scary as it was
when i was out there by myself like i
told you on the
on the solo trip like but being out
there
when there's just no point of reference
for there's no other people
you just feel exposed and you don't know
what mysteries lie in the dark
i think one of my favorite things was
what happened next in that
you know you came back and you told us
that story
like all three of you told the story
from your perspectives and then we went
on like
all of us sitting around the fire uh
you and i started telling stories kind
of building on what i was doing with
the stories i was already telling them
just telling the story about how we
would go camping
across the cape fear river and the one
time that you
invested like over an hour of
disappearing from me
and the rest of the friends that we
brought camping and like fully
committing to
like long-term
scaring the crap out of us by like
laying in the water
like like um like on a schwarzenegger
only my eyes and nose were above the
surface
like a gator and for a long time
you know telling them that story it was
they were you know it was just cool to
see
our boys so into us telling the stories
and i think we ended up telling a few
stories that we had written about in the
book of mythicality and
i just realized you know what you can't
just
you can't just write stories in a book
and expect your kids to read them they
were
these stories were still new to them it
was yeah like the story of
my brothers uh which in the book of
mythicality it's like a comic strip
so i don't know how well it's conveyed
but it's the story of my brother
in his middle school science fair
project which he called
birds which did not have a hypothesis
uh or you know any sort of experiment it
just had a bunch of dismembered birds it
was just
well i think it was with one bird that
he had shot
uh and then taken apart and put on his
poster board
um and uh to just show you the body
parts of the birds
it definitely seems like the kind of
thing a serial killer would do as a
middle school science fair project but
my brother is not a serial killer
um and they all knew him it was a
different time even my kids know cole so
it's like
they got a kick out of that story well
they got a kick lando in particular
that was the conversation in which i saw
lando kind of check out a little bit
yeah you know he's younger he's he's
such a sensitive soul
and uh he turns out he loves birds
so you know it's when you're
when you're adjusting to camping there
were a number of moments when i kind of
had to pull them to the side and say hey
we're still having a good time you know
he really
he he had a number of moments where he
bounced back he did
he was good and it was it was helpful
that like we had the security of the van
where
like we could we could um get snuggled
in our
blanket and kind of feel more secure
yeah
but the so the next morning uh we had a
drive out of
you know out of the campsite back to the
main area to go and
explore and find our next campsite and
locke you know is it
a lot of the kids these days and kids in
california i think especially are on a
slightly different schedule when it
comes to getting their
drivers permit and like license i mean
me and you were like as soon as
we turned 15 we got our drivers permit
as soon as we turned 16 that day i got
my license you know
things move a little bit slower and
obviously the pandemic has had an effect
on this
so lock basically just got his his
driver's permit
right before we left and he's not really
driven a car
we haven't really done the thing where
you just like let your kid drive when
they're 14
like i'll let you drive around the
neighborhood or something like that we
just haven't done that
don't really have that kind of
neighborhood i'm going to sneeze
do it in your sleeve okay
i'm not going to sneeze apparently he
went away
so he just got his permit so i'm like
this is the perfect
opportunity for him to drive you're in
the desert you're on a dirt road
uh there's not any other traffic i mean
in the vlog where we went off-roading
with
jeopardy we we you let him drive right
but he was in
this is for real this is giving them 100
controllers but yeah we're out there in
the middle of nowhere and it's just like
dirt roads leading back up to the main
road in fact
you told me you were going to do that
and i'm like well i'm going to go ahead
far enough so that
he won't be driving in my dust so i go
far ahead and i do not witness
anything that is about to happen
okay so this is a single
lane dirt road that has you know they
kind of come through there on a regular
basis with some sort of
scraper scraper that pushes the dirt to
the side almost like snow
banks right so there's no there's no
shoulder there's dirt banks
yeah and there's big rocks in these dirt
banks and you know one of the things
that happens when you start driving
is you don't know where your car is at
on the road
you don't you're on the left side and
you kind of feel like you're in the
middle but no you have a whole
piece of car to your right that so a lot
of new drivers
were hanging out to the right a little
too much i remember doing it
as a new driver and locke was doing that
almost immediately right
so there's some like big rocks in this
embankment i'm like locked you're too
far to the right you're too far to the
right come back to the left he's like i
don't think i am i'm like listen
and i actually said something like all
right
the only way that this is going to work
is if you assume
that when we are in the car together and
we have a different view
of driving i will always be right
okay during this stage of the
relationship that doesn't mean forever
but while you're the pupil and i'm the
teacher the only way we can do this is
just assume that i
in my driving experience know what i'm
talking about right
and he was and he actually was like okay
that makes sense so i was like and
here's how you can kind of tell where
you're at on the road anyway
so we're going along he's doing great
he's doing fine
you know i'm having to correct him a
little bit and kind of get him to move
to the center
but i'm trying to be calm and then all
of a sudden
i see another vehicle coming
towards us because again this is a
single lane we're going to have to sort
of move to the side to let each other
pass
i see that the uh the guy
has stopped to let and move to the side
to let us go
he's in like a subaru of some kind we
know not really
super off-road but like enough to be out
on this dirt road okay
but lock has seen the car and he has
come to a stop so that guy thinks that
he's saying that he should go yeah
but by the by the time i say oh he's
letting you go lock starts to go and so
does the other guy it's like what you
would typically do on foot
with someone yeah you're walking down
the side all right we're both going left
and we're doing a dance
and so you're playing chicken at this
point what ends up happening
is there's there's a little bit of
yelling from me
like uh he's saying something like no
just go no stop he wants you
i'm basically embodying the process
vocally it was i wasn't helping i'm sure
i wasn't helping
and lincoln's in the back seat just kind
of smiling a little bit smiling
so uh we get to the point where it kind
of just looks like
we're both just gonna drive past each
other oh with like one wheel up on this
dirt
sort of embankment on the side now you
both stopped and started how many times
at this point
four to five that's awkward man
that's okay it's okay to have one
tire up on this embankment when you're
an fj cruiser right
uh even though lock was getting so far
to the right that i thought he was going
to get high centered
or whatever the when basically you get
stuck in both wheels and on the
you know and so i was like you don't
stay left you're getting too far to the
right you know
slightly calmer than that the other guy
is doing the same thing
and we eventually get past him and then
lot gets back in the middle and goes and
i kind of and then i turn around and
look and i'm like
i think that guy got stuck
like he's in he's not in a off-road
vehicle
and he doesn't seem to be going anywhere
and so i was like look
i think that guy got stuck stop so lock
stops i said get out
i get in the i get in the driver's seat
i put it in reverse
i and i'm back all the way up to this
guy and sure enough
he's stuck but not only is he stuck but
three
additional vehicles in like a row
three guys who are on like an off-road
trip have come out of the mountain
same place you came from yeah are now
stopped and and they're out they're out
talking to this guy and then
within like the time that i get out of
my car they start pushing him off and
they get him off of the embankment and
they help him
i get out of the car i'm sure that guy
said some
nice things about what how about your
vehicle when i walked up to him i was
like hey man
hey listen i gotta and even though locke
is 16
i ki i was like hey i got a 15 year old
new driver he's driving for the first
time sorry about that he's like ah no
problem they got me it's it's great it's
it's fine whatever so
um so then i get back in the car i drive
a little bit i'm like well we still have
a lot of dirt road to go and i'm like i
stopped and i
was like listen okay let's start over
you know
that was something you couldn't
anticipate
you know it was probably your fault and
uh that was a difficult thing to
navigate in your first driving
experience
and i don't want you to be nervous and
have like a bad taste in your mouth on
your first driving experience so listen
let me give you another bad example
let's recenter
i'm going to calm down a little bit you
calm down a little bit because we were
both
yelling at each other we have very
similar personalities
and let's switch so
so we switch lock us in the driver's
seat i get in the passenger seat
and the three guys who have helped the
subaru
are now have come up behind us and
stopped right behind us so the lead car
is right behind us so lock puts it into
gear
presses the gas problem is the gear that
he chose
was reverse
how much gas did he press enough oh
enough for me to yell again
i'm telling you man the moment you when
you into
i mean anticipating going forward and
finding yourself in reverse
and knowing there's the guy right behind
us look look i think i just said his
name three times
and uh he ended up uh i don't know if he
put it
if he just hit the brakes or i just
moved it back into park either way
something there was a grinding noise oh
uh from our car
we did not ram direct i mean how how
awful would it have been you didn't hit
him several feet
which is close in a car right and uh how
awful would it have been for his
again his first driving experience to be
like running this guy off the road and
then backing into a guy who helped him
you know but after that at that point
what did you do
he said dad i don't want to drive
anything you gotta i'm sorry i got a
i got a 13 year old driver here
he's getting younger by the mist with
every mistake
uh and uh i felt for him because
i mean what i thought was gonna happen
was the same thing that happened as we
as we drove in which was no other cars
right yeah yeah yeah but on the way out
we have to run against this person
coming at us
we got three guys behind us so did you
switch back at that point switch back
and
and i drove out drove out and uh yeah he
actually did not end up driving again
that wasn't by design that was more
related to what ended up happening which
we'll talk about next
um but um anyway and i was waiting for
you and i was like why are they not here
yet
he gave me permission to tell that story
and i was like listen
and as we were driving out we actually
had a good conversation i was like
listen man
this kind of thing this is this is why
you do this
so you can have a story i was like or so
your dad can have a certain
this is why you go now you get a podcast
one day you can i was like
you've got your yeah yeah yeah you've
got your first driving story right and
and second and yeah first and second
two and for one and you're safe no one
got hurt
we can have a laugh about it you learn
something you move on and we actually
got to a good place you catch up with us
i hear the story uh and then we
we ended up driving all the way out of
the valley to beatty
to refuel and then we knew there was a
ghost town there that we kind of dropped
in on a second we ate some lunch then we
went in
we came back into the canyon on titus
canyon which is
um one of the more popular drives but
again that time of the year not many
not that many people there uh great
drive
the the best driver like um again it's
not
i wouldn't it's not technical it's just
a little
it's best to have high clearance but no
problem at all we saw a guy
we saw a guy in a maxima we did and it's
a it's a one-way thing so he
it's just do not recommend that do not
it's got a lot of washboarding
so this is a maximum you know when like
your car is kind of shaking as you go
but i also saw a guy on a bike doing the
whole thing there's a nuts
there is this and this is where i got
the drone footage
i don't know it probably won't be i
haven't looked at it probably won't be
that impressive
but like as you come down out of the
mountains and the canyon like you're
you're
you're on one of those like ice ice road
truckers
sort of roads yeah in which there's no
obviously there's no guard rail
and there's just a sheer drop into a
canyon on one side and it's
one lane wide and that's exciting right
i mean that
we we had a good time and then at the
end you get into the slot canyon
amazing where you're literally driving
in a canyon
yeah right one way and then you're and
it's not just winding back
back and forth so like you can never see
more than like
you know 15 yards in front of it and
that's why it's one way because
you couldn't that bottleneck yeah so we
go through that
and you know it was it was really cool
to go with the boys and have these
experiences like
for the first part of that trip lando
actually was asleep in the back i don't
know how he did
it it was so bumpy well we were we were
worried
you know yeah and and like there was a
couple places where lot would be like
dad
dad you like you sure about this because
it it it freaks you out
because you're like well if if or a rock
falls or if you lo
if you if you don't oh if you reach down
and change the radio station if
you got a radio station at that point
then you could careen off all systems
are online
when you are doing this and lincoln was
like i don't know how lando was doing
that's a good point
he well he was sleeping he was sleeping
that's the miracle of it all
so shep is i got shep to sit in the
front seat with me and like i'm like
you like steely dan because i know sh
you know
you've been training him on on what to
listen to he didn't know them by name
but like we're listening to some
some dan you know it's like i i really
feel like we had this kind of a
uncle moment you know it's like it was
cool for all of us to hang out and
you know uh incidentally lincoln told me
about uh
sleeping over at the house with with
locke
subsequent to this trip and i was like
everything he told me that he did
he was like well me and locke and rhett
we ate this and then me and locke and
rhett we watched a movie
and me and i was like it sounds like you
were hanging out with
locking red the whole time man i felt a
little threatened i was like you know
what this is this is good
uncle vibes we watched we watched uh
uh just a heinous horror movie he told
me
yeah but but it's um you know i just i i
think those two
that trip really fostered like an
extended family type of connection and
it was
you know uh that's just the magic of
camping is that you find yourself around
a campfire
and you can't over glamorize it and
trust me there's a lot of stuff the
majority of time is not glamorized but
then you find those moments that you can
kind of hold on to
like the steely dan moment when it's
like this amazing view and
seeing you i mean you guys were way
ahead of us we kind of and then you had
the drone by the time we caught up well
and then you just stopped at this
like a a ghost town like there was a a
place called lead field which is just
a place that sprung up when they thought
they were going to be mining lead and it
turns out that the place had a post
office for like 11 months
and 300 people lived there and you see
and they've got the pictures out there
what it used to look like and there's
still like three buildings standing that
you can
kind of walk around and and the minds
are closed the minds are closed but you
can walk up to them and look in and
they've got them kind of like yeah super
cool knocked off and the kids
the kids were really into this and like
us talking about like what would it have
been like to be out here
120 years ago yeah mining lead
you know i mean we come back and we're
like telling all these stories
and lily's like i kind of wish kind of
wish i would have gone
and i was like girl you can go next time
but it was it was cool for her to say
that out loud you know it's like she was
definitely not down
she did yeah she wasn't interested and i
mean her and christy were hanging out
and it was
it was good for them but so we leave
leadfield and like
again it's like you go through that slot
canyon at the end of that
trip and then you're like man we're
we're chasing daylight here
we got to find a place to um to camp for
the night
and again we didn't want to be in the
middle of the valley where there's it's
kind there are some like pockets of
civilization
like a gas station in a campground and
um
one hotel with like a bunch of palm
trees that was so
super strange i would say a resort a res
yeah a resort
it's just like super nice the only one
they let in there
to develop or maybe the only people
willing to do it or and to keep it up
but anyway we actually drive past that
and you had found
on the map like if we go up this this
candy called echo canyon
we start going up that on like that um
high clearance road a lot of a lot of
people camping there
and there was a truck in front of us
that was going so slow and like
he let us go by and then i'm like man i
am
we've been driving all day my shoulders
are sore i am exhausted i just feel like
i can't steer
this thing anymore um i i'm feeling
every bump in the road it's like i'm
glad we're almost to finding campsite
and with with every every rock we hit
and every turn we tried to make
i was like man this is if i didn't know
better
this this feels like when i wa my first
pickup truck
a 1987 nissan pickup had no power
steering
yeah i was like that's what this feels
like and then i was like
hold on i think that might be what
happened but
but we're also we haven't the thing we
haven't talked about it's getting dark
we were talking on our walkie talkies
yeah which
i that was having a walkie-talkie oh
yeah
being able to hey big boy over like
yep little boy over talking back and
forth to each other
like um that's the way to go on an
off-road trip like that there was lots
of checking in and also
lots of walky jokes walkie jokes yeah
walkie humor
if you'll look to your left right now
you'll see a big pair of boobies you
know
things like that it's just rocks but um
yeah yeah you got to make those kind of
jokes when the boys are just squint a
little bit
yeah right uh so you were i say that
because you were on the walk and you
were like i'm having trouble steering
um i'm tired i think i i i think there
might be something wrong with my power
steering and i'll be honest with you
when you said that i was like i just
think
i just think he just must be tired and
he's like you know it's
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with that brand new
super nice van it's getting harder by
the second to steer it's getting
darker by the second and we you know
we're having to pass all these people
camping and then we
go up at our slot canyon we go in a slot
canyon because that's and we found this
super cool
campsite and you hop out and i hop out
and i'm like man
i swear i've lost power steer i'm losing
power steering and you look under the
front and it's like
it's something's leaking it's wet under
there that's exactly what it is
and i'm like it's a scary feeling when
you're because we had gotten to the
point where it's like
we felt that isolation because that's
where we like to camp
and it was just it's there's a sinking
feeling of
this could get bad real quick you know
because it's like
it'd be so hard to get a vehicle in here
like a tow truck in here to get this
thing out and
so i'm like we we can't camp here we
gotta i gotta get it we gotta get this
thing back out of here right now
if it's leaking power steering before
it's
all of course bone dry which could
potentially do damage to the vehicle i i
got to try to get this thing back out
closer to civilization so we turn right
back around and go all the way back out
and by the time we got back out i'm like
hanging a right onto the
paved road i'm like it's i'm like
trying with all of my might to turn the
wheel to get this thing back because
this is not an 87 nissan pickup truck
no it's not and it's not a big vehicle i
mean we
we drove back down to the valley into to
a campground which said it was totally
full
furnace creek campground and uh because
i want to give a shout out to the uh
the campus the rangers yeah the park
rangers who were at the camp
because there were some myths they were
mythical beasts yeah but the night
before we talked to like the guy who
lives there permanently older guy who
was like well
they didn't show up you can stay in this
reservation wow lyle
love you lyle and then so we're like you
know what
i can i can still camp in this thing for
tonight
you know i called the owners or texted
the owners i told them what was up
uh they were understanding and helped me
problem solve in terms of like
what we're gonna do with this thing they
said well
since you're situated we have to find
out the next morning what the best
course of action is in calling like the
roadside assistance
and we get up the so that that night was
um
you know we were actually we were able
to have an actual fire there with like
not with the propane we went
to fire but i went to the fancy general
store
um which was like kind of a little like
outdoor mall resort kind of situation in
the middle of desert to get this uh
firewood that cost me
um thirteen dollars a bundle
and i got three bundles we had some
expensive wood we had a good night that
night
um the next day we find out that no they
can't come out and fix it
this is such a new vehicle they're gonna
have to come tow it
to the nearest place which is las vegas
and can i say that we
you know you talked about uh
our non-prowess when it comes to
diagnosing vehicular problems
but i say between the two of us we're
right about that we and
we we thought what had happened was is
that the hose to the pump had completely
come loose based on the spray pattern
oh of the forensics of the uh of the
power steering fluid and it turns out
that's exactly what had happened to the
car
uh i'll fast forward to when i'm like
well so we we arranged for the tow truck
to come and then the owner said
we're just going to get him to tow it
all the way back to los angeles how many
three and a half hours
from there was four and a half hours
four and a half hours
and they told the tow truck came from
l.a
picked it up and then went to four and a
half hours back and it couldn't be fixed
because
the clamp is a proprietary clamp that
you found out
very soon after that the mercedes-benz
talked about it online had
uh issued a recall well that's what i
found out weeks later so just to close
that loop yeah whenever
i was returning stuff to the owner that
i had taken out of the van she was like
i got
i just got the notice today the recall
for them to fix that so
you know i know i didn't do anything
inappropriate but it it made me feel
better
that like hey this is a mercedes problem
not a
link probably a link problem um
but that took most of our day because we
had to drive all the way out to
you had to drive me out to the nearest
uh
place to rent a car all the way out of
the valley and bring
rent a minivan bring it all the way in
and so we kind of lost today
significant downgrade and how cool you
seemed the rest of the trip
yeah you went from having a van that
was so big hashtag van life goes to
hashtag minivan life
totally different minivan life was not
you know i i didn't want to be in
pictures with you and your minivan
anymore
i took a picture of the uh sprinter veen
being loaded up on the
on the right i got that on video too oh
cool drone footage
no drone but i got that on video i want
to see that that's cool
um last story but we had it yeah we
gotta tell
we had enough we all hopped in the
minivan as as the sun was setting and we
drove to this one candy corn it was
called like sunset
canyon or something like that
and where we knew it was going to get
dark
but that didn't mean that meant i
grabbed a jacket but it didn't mean that
i grabbed
flashlights or headlamps or anything
because we did not do that
right but as it was getting dark it was
clear
and me and locke were actually we kind
of got up ahead of you guys it was and
we were walking ahead of everybody
and uh again it was this crazy
canyon that's got this like chalky white
rock that's almost like dirt meets rock
like dirt that hasn't yet become rock
so sedimentary uh rock that is still
very sedimenty
right and a lot of people are walking
out as we're walking in
up into this basically another slot
canyon but you could see
that the moon was going to be bright and
actually as the sun was going down and
the moon was coming up
you could already see your moon shadow
pretty crazy
and i was like oh this is going to be
fine like we don't need we don't need
lights let's just keep going
i i will say when it was all said and
done i'm like lando what was your
favorite thing he was like the night
hike
because at a certain point we started
calling this all right guys this is the
night hike
we're doing it you know um and
we went in a few miles you get all the
way to like you get up against this like
sheer mountain faces
they call it like the cathedral the red
cathedral cathedral
yeah there's red um rock wall
and you and locke had gotten a a lot
further ahead a matter of fact i
convinced myself that you guys are going
to try to scare the crap out of us
and i was not that happy about that but
when we got to the cathedral
you and locke yeah so we got to the end
of the end of the line
and like there was a cave he had to walk
through like to get to the final end of
the trail
and we could hear this is so weird we
could hear
you guys talking to each other crisp
like i could
make out the words that you were saying
and so
i wanted to make sure that you were
going to come all the way and you
weren't going to turn around
and so i was like link and i yelled as
loud as i could
didn't hear anything no response but you
could hear me
like there was just talking acoustic
issue where i couldn't get my voice to
go to you
and i think it might be because you were
in this little k
like cave thing it was coming out of the
cave but i couldn't get my voice to go
into the cave
right no one will ever know acoustic
it's a mystery it's an acoustic mystery
it's an acoustic mystery that keeps me
up
it keeps you up at night you're thinking
about it but then you finally show up
and it's pretty cool because it at this
point you kind of you go into the
the sheer wall of the cathedral and then
you kind of double back and kind of go
go up this um like pyramid of
dirt to like this ridge that
then we started taking pictures of the
kids i took a silhouette picture
by the by the moonlight and it was super
cool
and so i'm down below you're up a little
bit ahead of me
um taking a picture of all of the boys
up there on the ridge
and then we take the pictures and we're
like all right let's start heading back
down
and just as we start heading back
down there's some sort of uh
there's a little bit of a kerfuffle like
there's something going on there's like
some shimmying happening
and some grunting as people are coming
down uh
start to come down and the first thing
that i hear said
is um i could tell
people were concerned and lando says
please nobody say any bad words
and so i'm like oh okay what has
happened
well apparently he had picked up on a
pattern uh which is if things went wrong
there were bad words that were said
and that please nobody say any bad words
did that upset him i was like
what time um it turns out what had
happened
was shepard uh who let me just
go on record and say that shepard is
actually
has a great track record with keeping up
with his phone
not so much with my other son uh but
great track record of keeping up with
his phone and
not not losing things but shepard
had dropped his relatively new phone
that had proceeded to slide
down this cliff side that was probably i
mean we're talking like a 45 degree
angle
yeah that just kind of went down into
the lower part of the red cathedral
which was a dark abyss really and we
could not see
anything and even when we shined our
phone lights onto the slope we were like
there's no way
that we're going to find this but it
felt like the phone has got to be
right there and so did you say any bad
words
i didn't say any bowers because lando
said not to i don't
oh no that's true no i said one what did
i say i said
i think what after after looking for
about 15 minutes and like
crab walking down that 45 degree slope
and kind of feeling like
you don't know what you could tumble
into you can't you kind of started
getting a little bit more grouchy
well here's the thing um and i'd walk
down below
because i was down at the bottom and you
were up at the top and the phone was
somewhere in the middle
as i was walking down this
cliff side i was thinking to myself
am i going to die trying to find my
kid's phone
and this is he's he's never going to
forgive himself like
is he going to watch this is he going to
watch his dad tumble off this cliff
in the moonlight and be like ah my dad's
dead because
i dropped my phone so that's when i
started to joke with them
about that yeah again lando
you know didn't like that yeah because i
was like all right shepard here i am
going to find your phone this might be
the last time we talk
you say you're twisted yeah i'm a little
twisted scaring the crap out of children
but i also
felt like i wasn't gonna die and i
also it was remembering birds it was it
wasn't that was my brother and it wasn't
like
at the end of the cliff it just dropped
off the nothingness it was just the
trail
so i was like right at worst i'll just
be badly injured
right you you're not going to fall into
oblivion you're going to fall to the
trail that where i'm standing
but i would as you know i'm scared of
heights i was trying to
overcome that and not let anybody know
uh but eventually i was like i can't see
this phone and i'm afraid that i can't
if i if i get to a place where i can't
get back up then we're going to be like
calling in the chopper
you know assuming there is one and so
come back up we go around to the bottom
and we get down there and shepherd of
course is
already climbing up the cliff to try to
get his phone
he might be addicted to screens that
might be what was driving him
uh he's way up there and i'm a little
worried about him
and then i'm like well i gotta go up
there too
so i went up there and uh
five minutes passed we i ended up
finding the phone
i was able to spot it with my light and
we got it and uh we got out with
only one maybe two curse words said and
no injuries
yeah lando was cool with that he still
said that's that's the end of that story
he still said my favorite thing was the
night hike so you
oh you didn't ruin it for him good
completely
but uh yeah that's the catch phrase now
if if anything wrong
happens first thing you need to say is
okay please nobody's saying any bad
words
[Laughter]
no matter i'm about to tell you
something you're not going to want to
hear just don't say any bad words
it ended up being an incredible trip i'm
so glad i yeah we're saying that it was
your idea
i'm so glad you had that idea um
i wish we uh had had already done it
more
you know now that our kids are the age
that they are um
but and i still want to go next time
that's the good news is that before we
went on that trip
i think in lock's mind it was like i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna do this again
but by the end he was talking about how
good of a time he had had
how much he liked being out in nature
and then
on the way back you know i drove
loch and lincoln and i let
them be my dj and uh
boy the musical uh
journey that we went on
that was started in sort of dad music
territory
john mayer et slowly
started kind of getting into uh some
some hip hop
that that i enjoy
then began to transition into
uh maybe some modern hip-hop
uh a la 21 savage
and uh talk about bad words
we made up for all the bad words that we
had uh
held back in the presence of lando we we
went
well over the limit if you include what
the artist is
including what if you include what the
artist said in the last hour of our trip
my van did not have the capability to
connect to my phone
and most of the time i don't know about
that mercedes but i forgot no you're
right i'm in a minivan at this point
it did not connect to my phone um and
we we hardly had any radio stations so
the only thing i listened to was how bad
my kids and your kids
feet smelled yeah like we had to pull
over so they could get you you know
shepherd was wearing shoes with no socks
and then i was like
then he'll take his shoes off when he
gets in the car yeah and i'm gonna let
him do that i'm like man you gotta
we had to pull over so you could go up
to your car pull out that drawer and get
some socks out
it's like a biohazard we had a great
trip um
it's our privilege to have shared it
with you on this ear biscuit a great way
to kick off the gear you know it's just
it's just a good thing to to build on
you know is that we can be outdoors i
still don't know what i want to do about
the van
like if there's a van in my future i i
think i'm just going to stay on the
rental front because this kind of scared
me a little bit like
something that drastic that required
that much towing
like i just i think it was nice to rent
it i think the rental i think the rental
is nice yeah is the way to go for one of
those yeah it's not that hard that's
what i'm leaning
towards at this point and
it was a good trip man and next week
we will talk about uh assuming it seems
like every time
we go somewhere or there there's a break
there's stories to tell
so we're going to talk about uh the
holiday the holiday break
whatever came from that yeah i'm
assuming that we'll talk about that but
hashtag your biscuits let us know if you
want to weigh in on any of this
oh and i got a if i got a i got a
recommendation
yeah first wreck of twenty years um
i found this series on hbo max forgive
me if you don't have hbo max but uh it's
just
you know just another reason to get it
um
calm is this is is one of the apps that
does meditations but they have a series
do you know about this series
on hbo's got a world of calm
and um let's see there's a number of
episodes but it's
uh basically it's reminiscent of
like the the calming nature of watching
primitive technology on youtube you're
just watching somebody in a process
they have a more meditative it's much
more edited
and produced version of that it's like a
it's the most calming documentary
that you could watch like intentionally
calming documentary i've only watched
one episode
give me an example the episode i watched
is called
living among the trees narrated by
keanu reeves oh and it is a guy
who takes one felled
tree and turns it into a canoe
so like a like a a single tree hall
canoe and it's you just you know he
doesn't talk
there's no interviews it's just like
calming music
and footage of him narrated by keanu
of him making a canyo how old i mean how
long is this
um this episode is it's 23 minutes long
so it's super cool to watch uh that's
the only one i've watched there's
uh one about snowfall the birds
journey narrated by nicole kidman i mean
this sounds like i'm giving an ad but
it's just
a really cool idea well hbo max has been
a sponsor yeah that's
right the coral city narrated by lucy
liu is
episode one glass maker by zoe kravitz
narrated by the great beyond narrated by
idris elba this is a good idea yeah this
is
this is super cool oh a horse's
tail like t-a-l-e who does that one
kate winslet oh my the gift of chocolate
dang there's so there's 10 episodes on
this thing world to come check it out
like it's it's nice to have to be able
to watch something that like
kind of feeds your soul and gives you
rest and doesn't just distract you but
it is a meditative experience i need to
watch that before i help my son drive
there you go man or maybe after or
during
all right we'll speak at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best